le système des retraites qui serait à
l'équilibre des régimes qui feraient des
bénéfices baissez l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 60 ans au contraire
l'augmenter à 67 ans sur le sujet des
retraites on entend tout et n'importe
quoi à longueur de journée dans le débat
politique dans les médias de la part des
syndicats au modem on considère qu'il
est important d'être honnête avec les
Français de leur présenter l'effet et
simplement l'effet pour qu'il puisse se
faire une opinion et décider en libre
conscience parce qu'on ne gouverne pas
sans votre adhésion sans débattre de vos
droits avec vous sans construire
ensemble l'avenir notre pays François
Bayrou la démontré avec le Haut
Commissariat au Plan le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites l'a
également écrit le système de retraite
va être en déficit lourd avec 30
milliards d'euros par an
30 milliards c'est l'équivalent du
budget du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et de l'enseignement supérieur
c'est l'équivalent du budget du
ministère de l'Intérieur et de la
justice cumulée on ne peut pas continuer
à laisser la dette se creuser cette
dette qui nuit à nos services publics au
porte-monnaie de chaque famille à
l'avenir des futurs générations la
réalité c'est donc qu'il faut agir sur
ce système que réformer est
indispensable une réforme oui mais pas
simplement une réforme qui augmentera
l'âge de départ à la retraite en vous
demandant de travailler toujours plus
parce que les parcours de vie de chaque
personne sont différents parce qu'on ne
fait plus le même métier dans la même
entreprise toute sa vie il faut être
capable de tenir compte de tous ces
facteurs pour le départ à la retraite
prendre en compte la pénibilité de
chaque emploi parce qu'être maçon
éboueur pompier caissier cadre
administratif ou infirmier ça n'a pas le
même impact prendre en compte les
carrières longues en comptabilisant
plutôt la durée de cotisation parce que
certaines français et certaines
françaises ont commencé à travailler
très jeune cette réforme des retraites
devra être individualisée en tenant
compte également de la situation des
femmes des choix de vie des carrières
hachées comme des carrières longues du
travail à temps partiel en somme tenir
compte simplement des différences de
parcours de vie pour être plus juste que
le système de retraite ne l'a été
jusqu'ici mais il y a aussi d'autres
leviers au-delà de demander toujours
plus d'efforts aux salariés l'arme la
plus puissante pour le rééquilibrage des
retraites c'est le plein emploi grâce à
l'action notre majorité présidentielle
nous avons réduit le taux de chômage à
un niveau historiquement bas nous devons
poursuivre nos efforts pour que chaque
Français puisse obtenir un emploi avec
une rémunération digne peu importe son
âge peu importe son niveau de
qualification
c'est un sujet aussi pour nos aînés
souvent peu considérer dans les
entreprises mis de côté près de la
moitié
de la retraite en étant au chômage
pourtant nos seniors sont une richesse
notamment pour nos jeunes auxquels ils
ont tant à transmettre enfin un effort
pourrait être demandé aux entreprises en
relevant d'un point à leur cotisation
pour financer les retraites s'ennuyer ni
à leur trésorerie ni obulletin de paix
des salariés il y a des voies de
rééquilibrage il y a des droits à
définir en discutant en débattant en se
concertant avec chacune et chacun
d'entre vous si on veut garantir les
retraites de nos aînés qui ont travaillé
toute leur vie si on veut permettre à
nos enfants d'avoir une retraite c'est à
nous d'avoir le courage de mener cette
réforme tous ensemble avec le Modem nous
ferons une réforme des retraites oui
mais une réforme de justice sociale
avant tout